Welcome everybody to another Zoom call
Historyfinder to always
Check the members page the member site will page for any
New updates or an outspins or anything like that
I think I do have some new announcements that listed here comes just a screen shot from weeks ago
You can self-schedule now as a member at the
Members reduced prices. You don't have to call a talk to Marine. You can self-schedule out of there
so
I think that's the only announcement there was
Okay, let's jump into the questions and get started. First question
And I use
my phone
While running the right machine. So if you're laid down
city down
Right in your right machine. Can you pick up your phone and talk to somebody on the phone? Can you go on the internet and
Scroll Facebook while you're doing the right the answer is yes you can
You may have some interference at different times on different frequencies
To make goof up your phone a little bit or slow down your
your
Your connection or something like that, but no typically
You don't have you should not have any problems. Will your phone
interfere with the frequencies coming out of the right ball and interfere with your treatment?
No, not at all. You can there's no harm in that
It's not going to interfere with the frequencies coming out of the right ball
Further questions and I can think of the tie to this. Can I use the IMF PEMF? Can I do the right while I do my PEMF?
Yes, yes, you can there's a totally different frequencies
They're not going to overlap. They're not going to cancel each other out you can do that
Can I do my red light therapy while I do my right? Yes, you can there's no harm in that
So you know, we have a person that does the sauna they have kind of rigged it up more they bring the
The ball goes in through the door and goes into their sauna. Is that gonna hurt the machine?
No, no because I wouldn't bring the machine in the sauna
But if the bulb is in there should be fine
So that person does the right while he's in the sauna great
So you could try to do more than one thing at a time. That's always
Why is use of time so no there shouldn't be any issues with frequencies of the cell phone
Certainly will not mess up their frequencies that the treatment frequencies from the right the only thing with using your
phone with the right could possibly be
Your phone
Could slow down or you could be goofier something like that, but we haven't had that issue
Next question my collagen powder has methylated multivitamins should I discontinue
So I presume this is a collagen powder that you're using that you chose to purchase separately that's not something I recommended
Um, if it has methylated supplements in it, I would say to discontinue using it
And again, I have some blog posts on why cancer patients shouldn't be generally taking methylated supplements
And of course the the exception to that rule is if a person has elevated herbal cysteine
Then we need to use folate
Um, and maybe methyl comolamine to help reduce homocysteine levels
But if you don't have elevated homocysteine and you have a diagnosis of cancer
You shouldn't be taking methylated vitamins even if your family members
That don't have a diagnosis of cancer
Can they take methylated multivitamins?
Well, yes, I know you just have to be careful
As um eat anybody has to be careful taking too much
methylated supplements because
They probably haven't had their genetic profile done and if they have defects in different pathways
excess
methylated supplements can push different pathways and can cause other issues. So
The person doesn't have cancer or if they do have cancer and they have defects in their biopterate pathway
I could push that pathway and cause some mood issues some
Ager issues rage issues
uncontrolled behavior um, and you see this
quite frequently so
I would be careful taking excess
methylated supplements from is
When supplements, you know, when the supplement companies found out about
The MTHFR defect. This is about 10-15 years ago
All the companies started adding methyl tetrahydrofolate methyl comolamine to
You know, many of their different supplements so that if you're taking multiple supplements
You could be getting methylated
volate methylated
comolamine
In multiple supplements and many times it's
far exceeding
They recommend a daily allowance
So it's you're getting way too much methylated supplements
But as a cancer patient you have to be even more diligent
To read your labels and to be careful on excess methylation
Because that turns off tumor suppressor genes and one could even make an argument
Maybe no one of the world is making this argument by me
But the high use of methylated supplements
Could actually be contributed to the increase
cancer
Phenomena that we're seeing today that's at least a piece just one little piece
So even natural people wow my how did I get cancer?
I mean to have it taking supplements and doing things, you know, naturally and eating organic for so long and now I am this cancer
Well look at your supplements you've been taking methylated supplements
For the last 10 years thinking that you're doing good for yourself and yet you are actually
Increasing your risk for cancer because you're you're turning off tumor suppressor genes
Just like if person has a lot of tumor suppressor gene defects
Um, you're basically silencing it by taking excess methyl groups
Just my two cents all right next question
When I do a follow-up cheek swab there doesn't always seem to be major changes. Why
Well, I think I have a video on cheek swab tested on the member site too
But in general, I mean typically there's not always going to be giant changes, you know, your body changes gradually
It doesn't always
Be that that you know, your body's going to call for a completely different protocol. It's pretty rare
Um, you might change from you know, we might be doing one basic cancer killing protocol and change and tweak and change to something else
Um, especially if a person's not doing good. I'm gonna dig a little deeper and ask deeper questions
Make sure that you know, that something else might just be a hair better
So don't expect giant changes. No
And again, well, why would a person do a cheek swab retest
It would be if there was giant changes in
Their symptoms if there was giant changes in objectifiting. Let's say their cancer and doubled
Um, in size or something like that or
If you know, you're just okay, but on this protocol for the last four months um, I just want to see if I need to tweak something
Or hey, I've been doing really good for the last year and I don't want to take as many supplements as there's things that I can hope it
So those are the reasons why you would do a cheek swab test and there might not always be major changes
Next question my husband pulled the muscles in his neck and stretched his nerves as well
What program would be helpful to run he has been to a carpractor and
It has been two years
Okay, so
Two years since he had this injury and it's not getting better
Oh, then um, would the right be helpful? Well, sure that right can be helpful
I would say accelerated healing. I would say inflammation
There may be other precipitating
Uh, co-orbidities that is hindering healing process
so if uh
You know, you're talking about your neck if there was you know sometimes you have to go to a different carpractor too
So if you go to the same carpractor, you're not getting good results
In carpractor, there's a lot of different techniques
So um, you may have to find somebody who uses a technique that actually
Um, is analyzing your spine and correcting things instead of just making just adjustments
So you might have to look for a different type of carpractor. Other other therapies that could be used
Tens unit for sure, I would think
But again, try to get to the diagnosis of what the cause is
Um, so
I don't I don't know. I don't remember who asked this question
So I don't know how old your husband would be but definitely as we age
You can have degenerative joint disease and then if you
Damage your neck you get some sort of twisted action or car accident or something like that
You could have damaged to the joint
capsules themselves and
Arteratic changes that go along with that so um
A looking at other things as law as well as musculoskeletal things could be helpful
um
So as far as the rife goes, I would say accelerated healing and I would say inflammation try the pain programs
Um, if you want to set it haven't set up uh, again, I don't remember who this was
But if you want to have him set up a consult with me
I may have some other suggestions to look at as well if I get a little bit more information
Next question can I be using different a different computer on the internet while using the rife
It kind of goes to that other question as well
So can I be sitting in my bed running the rife and then open up my
iPad or my laptop
It'd be on the internet while using the rife. Yes, you can
So the only caveat to that would be it you know, it could
interfere with your computer function
If the ball was sitting right next to the computer or the ipad that's just a possibility
Is the ipad or the computer the laptop that I'm using it to interfere with my treatment?
That's my big question. I don't want it to interfere with my treatment
I'll stay off of it if it's not going to if it's going to hurt my treatment. It's not going to hurt your treatment
So no, you could you're fine to
To do that. It will not affect the frequencies coming out of the ball
It won't affect your treatment negatively in any way
That's question
How do I get all my programming complete in my night program?
I can't stay in bed for the entire time
Well
This is a common scenario
So many times I'll write the programs between eight and nine hours long
And then you got some people that they just sleep seven hours every night
So if that's the case and you are missing like more than an hour to half every night that I will
You know, let me know and I will shorten up your programs
um
If you're only missing a half an hour a night
They're just the the frequencies are cycling through them. So
Um, I just said somebody sent me an email
They're not on this zoom call, but they sent me an email say
Another practitioner wants them to run these three very specific frequencies. I don't remember what it was was like
47.79 hurts and I don't know
39.82 hurts and 147.3 hurts and they want them run for four hours each day
Okay, so
I haven't talked to that person yet as they just sent me an email
But they're that practitioner who's asking them to do that is not understanding frequencies
very well
Because from from a rife frequency standpoint, you're really not supposed to run a specific frequency
For more than about three to six minutes
Um now you can you can run it for three minutes and then run something else for three minutes and another thing for two minutes and another thing for three minutes and and then in an hour later you can run it again
That's a frequency but you would never run a frequency
For just like four hours you would just you would never do that that could be actually harmful
All your programs you could actually look through your programs if you want please don't
Mess around in your programs because you can mess it up
but when you hit run on your
On your rife the true rife and the atelier Robin you can actually see the program that I wrote that's in there
It has all these numbers and it has pulse rates and
duty cycles and dwells and all these different things but command dwell
DWEL is actually how long it will stay on the given frequencies and tell that dwell cycle has changed again
So if I write dwell and then I write a whole bunch of numbers underneath there those are the frequencies and then you know
Could go down a whole line and then there's another dwell so my dwell at 180 and then down a whole bunch of lines of the dwell at 80
That means it dwells at 180 seconds and then if I change the dwell down below
To 80 then it dwells at 80 seconds. You would never dwell for how many seconds is is four hours? I don't know
So for hours times 60 minutes per hour times 60
Seconds per you so you could do the math, but there's no
You don't dwell that long and that comes from the understanding. I mean royal rife said you should never run a frequency more than three minutes
He was running radio frequencies that could be very dangerous
And his machine it so they could actually burn somebody
Um, but it's still a
An understanding in the rife community. You don't dwell more than about six minutes
That would be your maximum dwell and you do that very infrequently
so um
Given let's say let's pretend breast cancer is the program that we're running there are about a hundred known frequencies for breast cancer
And I will program them the your program through those frequencies
You know for maybe let's say three hours and then they cycle again then they cycle again
So if you're missing a half hour of your program every night at the end you're getting those frequencies throughout the night
So we don't need to shorten your program
I'm very hesitant to short as somebody says oh my programs are eight to the half hours long and I
I sleep eight hours and I don't sleep any longer than that. So I feel like I'm
Missing time. You're really not missing time
Um, you're getting those frequencies
So understand if I'm gonna shorten somebody's program. So I I had a gentleman
Cross-take cancer. He says I only sleep six hours. So I'm not getting all my programs. So okay
Well, we we had that made sense
So we shorten this program, but you're but the negative of that is we're shortening the dwell that it's running on every frequency
Which is good and bad, you know, it's good because you're not missing it out. You're only in bed for six hours
But you're missing out on three possible more hours of treatment time
So you there's a balance that one plays and I don't want everybody to say well
I want you to shorten my program too because you know, I miss in 20 minutes on every night
No, don't don't do that
But if you're missing like two hours an hour and a half
Let's say you're you only sleep six and a half hours
No, there's just no exceptions to that you're never in bed longer that
Then let me know I'll gladly shorten the dwell and compact your program
You're not getting as much treatment though
So that's the negative
So somebody that's
Staying in bed for eight hours and getting their rest and relaxing or maybe going to bed
I only sleep for seven and a half hours
We'll go to bed early and read your Bible for a half an hour. At least you're getting eight hours of program. We didn't
Follow my thinking of that. So just just go along with it. I want everybody to say I want you to shorten my program
I'm gonna have to charge you for that because it's a pain of the butt to do that and it takes time
But I understand if you're missing an hour and a half each night
But if you're only missing a half hour on the average of each night
No, you're you're getting those frequencies
um
We're not going to shorten your program for that. Hopefully that I explain that okay
Okay, next question
When would I want to run other programs on my p220? So this is the atelier Robin right
and you could say the same thing on the true right so when would you want to run other programs out of your right
Anytime you want to if you have other cold morbidities
Uh, let's say a person's you know hurt their knee so they want to run accelerating healing and they want to put that by down by their knee
You don't want to add that to your night program. Just do that during the day that you get a chance for right before you go to bed or something
I have a cold. I feel really sick. I'm just really feeling like I'm coming down with somebody you could do the overnight cold and flu program today
And skip your cancer program of course that depends on if your cancer is raging
We don't want you to not suffer from a cold so let your cancer grow
You have to use your carbon sense in that you can run other programs on your right anytime
I did pull up this slide that goes along with this question
This is what the p220's program looks like. This is what the atelier Robin's program looks like
Everything is in a file that says doctor cutters alphabetical ARR. That's why alphabetical list file
Well, these things are folders this thing right here that you see it my cursor
And then this thing is a file. These are all Microsoft icons Microsoft came up with these icons
Backward Windows came up. This looks like a little bit of a folder. This looks like a piece of paper
So that's a file
This is a file and these are these are programs themselves. This is just the this is just the piece of paper in the file
So if you clicked on the orders manual which
Don't click on that but you do get all the orders values with it
If you click on my special sets click on that there may be some programs that you want to run that are dealing with your current
Comorbidity that you might want to run and then I have a file of doctor cutters 11th harmonic pathogen kill programs
Exactly when it sells since there's probably about 30 programs in there that are specific pathogen
Most common pathogen kill cold and flu. I have a certain virus. I have
You know beryllia infection. I have certain infections are in there different
Parasites and different things like that that are just listed in that file that you can run that are 11th harmonic
And then it's got all the alphabetical programs that I wrote all these programs I wrote
um, and the ones that are that are
The ones are all of them are written in the 11th harmonic if it's appropriate. So
They are that's what you you can run any of those programs now
What I did it put on here which would be on top because I just took this screenshot of my picture yesterday when I put this
This uh together would be your file a a your name with the data on it would be on top above this
Um, so that's what your folder would look like and you can click on any of these and run any of these programs and you can scroll through the alphabetical list
Uh, and run any of these programs now the true right everybody's listening to me has had their true right for a long time
So they already know how to get through their programs and moving
Move around in the program itself
But uh, that's how a Microsoft program looks
Um, and that's how you maneuver through that program certainly you can run any programs that you want
But you definitely want to be writing your answer program um, if uh, you know your cancer is still active
Okay
Next question
Before starting with cutters clinic, I went to a naturopath should I continue
Well, you can so you know
Understand, uh, you know, I have always said you know, I want you to do what you feel like God is leading you to do
We have lots of people that are talking they're going to a carpractor or going to a naturopath or going to a nutritionist and getting advice as well and
And sometimes it's really good to have somebody local that you can talk to and that makes you feel good and and
There's all sorts of benefits to that and if you see a benefit to that then by all means
You don't go with that
But please
At least you don't have to take my opinion you don't have to agree with me
You don't have to do anything. I tell you to do but this kind of question like this one
Back here
My college and powder has methylated multivitiveness should I discontinue these are the kind of questions
I need you to ask or I want you to ask
Um, because I you know, there's lots times where a person will have a question where they're taking things that I would have never recommended
Now you might get a totally different argument from your naturopath and no, I want you to take that you need methylated vitamins
I'm you know, sometimes people think I give too long of answers
Um, I had somebody to the day that it was unhappy with me because I explained things to them
Of the call too long
And I get it. I'm sorry. That's just the way I am. That's why I try to
To give you
Education so that you are not just following somebody
Um, but you're educated so you're making your own
Conscious decisions because now you know something that you didn't know before
So that's why I try to tell you about just against methylated vitamins
There's a reason why a cancer patient wouldn't want to be taking methylated vitamins
Um, so I'm trying to give you that data so you can arm yourself now
There's a lot of practitioners that don't understand that
There's a probably there's tons of stuff. I don't understand and I learn every day
But when we're open to learning then we grow
And we're better for it, I believe
so um
I'm not going to apologize for over teaching
Um, so go ahead and go to your nature path if you want to
Um, they can have wonderful benefits for a lot of different things
But if they do recommend supplements that you have any questions about just ask that's what these zoom calls are for
Just ask and I may say
Sure, there's no harm in taking that
And or I may say I don't think you should take that and then you could make that decision
You don't have to do what I tell you to but I'll give you my honest opinion. So
Absolutely you can continue to take it and somebody on the phone the other day that said
I really want to find an herbalist
What do you want to find an herbalist for because I need to know what supplements to take this is a case here
I said well that's what I am. Oh, they were pleasantly surprised
Okay, well, you know
Ask me questions if I don't know something you know me well enough. I'll say I don't know
I don't know that answer. I'm not familiar with that
But if I do know something
I'll give you my opinion and sometimes I need to correct that opinion because I was wrong
But let's just learn together
So I want you guys to be educated make educated decisions so that you
You could help other people and not just follow someone
Okay, next question are too many supplement capsules bad for a digestive tract
If so can I can the contents be emptied into a juicer smoothie?
Um, I would agree that yes too many supplement capsules themselves can be irritating to some people's stomach
Um, so the only ones you can't open and put in are ones that are a time released supplement
Usually they'll say that at the bottle it's a time released
Diasid or time released whatever
Um, those ones you really shouldn't open up okay, but anything else that if it's not time released
And it's not a gel you know
Then if it's a powder in the capsule by all means you can open it up
I think that's a great idea to open it up and put it in a smoothie. Yes
Now this next question is kind of long and I did talk to this person of the phone about this
But I wanted to put this up there because I wanted to actually commit to the doctor
And you'll see why when I want to answer this
So I talked to this person of the phone and then they sent me what their doctors
Assess what did plan was
And I was impressed because
You wanted to get that I went back on a fedman pulse of four days, uh three days off two weeks ago
Total of eight days and my liver enzymes blew up my ALT went from 19 to 149 and my ST went from 20 to 115
Um, treatment team wanted to give me tests
Uh, and cortisone medication to counter a possible side effect for my chemo or immunotherapy
I can clean and told them that I started taking fedman
We all agreed to retest and see if my numbers go down by the end of the week
Which would be about five days off fedman. I also go back to Mayo
Next week for additional MRI CT scan and lab with
chemotherapy and immunotherapy to resume on 12 18 or 19
I've also stopped the methylene blue the low-dose miltruxode
Should I adjust any of the supplements that have been prescribed to help lower the liver numbers?
I was instructed to stop taking tudcub because it can conflict with the chemo and immunotherapy regimen of us
um
So I got this after we spoke and um
It's um
This person sent me their labs and I said to me the email that they should just stop the
fedman because that's what I thought right off the bat that was causing the ST and ALT
Remember we've spoken before about this phenomena
Many times a drug interaction with your liver will rave
Rays will elevate ALT and ST but will spare alcohol and phosphatase
If we have a metastasis to the liver or metastasis to the bone
um
How you could help differential diagnosis that with a blood test is that if if there's metastasis to the liver
You'll have elevated ALT, AST and alcohol and phosphatase and milirubid usually
um
If it's metastasis to the bone you'll have elevated alcohol and phosphatase
No elevation of bilirubid no elevation of ALT no elevation of AST
It's also possibly on an elevation of calcium
So you're trying to differential diagnosis so it's looked at that blood test
It made most sense to me that it was a drug interaction
And this person was unfedmented we know we've said this
dozens of times already
If you're unfedmented 50% of the people don't detoxify it well it affects their liver
And how is it going to affect their liver? It could just their liver and it will elevate ALT AST
That's what I thought right off the bat that told this person to stop the fedment and
Immediately when this person told their doctor their doctor went right to that too
And I just wanted to say
We just need more doctors like this because
We this is the first time that I've heard
Uh, the oncologist the medical field say the same thing which I'm really happy
So they said stage 4 low
Atto carcivil with braid metastasis the plan was to stay on these medications
um
Braineradiation was completed in September planning to follow up with mail
Suspect this could be related to the digestion of fedbendazol
Which is proven to cause liver toxicity
So I was really glad to see that
You guys you have to
Be aware that if you're on fedbendazol it can be toxic to your liver if you don't detoxify it
Like I said about 50% of the people don't detoxify it well the only way you're going to know
You're not going to necessarily have any symptoms this person probably didn't have liver pain
But the symptoms the objective sign of that is going to be elevation of
ALT and AST and the only way you're going to know that is to get a blood test
That's why you are promised to me if you're going to go on fedbend you're going to get regular blood tests
And what you would get is a comprehensive metabolic panel comprehensive metabolic panel
If you just went and got a basic metabolic panel it doesn't include AST and ALT
So you have to ask for a comprehensive metabolic panel
You can get just what's called a liver panel too
That doesn't have the other things in it but it's best to get a comprehensive metabolic panel
Because then you could differential diagnose with the elevated or not elevated calcium
So that's what I did use that as another teaching tool
Next question
tumors are shall we not put CT scan as if they are growing after two months of the protocol should I be concerned
We should always be concerned if your tumors are growing
Ever two months after the protocol we did address a question like this
Last week the same thing. I mean I live right for two months. How come my tumors aren't shrunk
Hey, you you came to me and you have cancer and how fast where they growing
How faster they're growing now if they're growing as fast or faster after being on two months of any protocol
You have to reassess the protocol makes some different changes
If it slowed down the growth the growth is still there
But it slowed down then then you might make the choice not to make any changes
It takes time to put the brakes on something
But certainly if let's say if I if I have
Objective data showing let's say I have a breast tumor pretend so the breast tumor was three millimeters
A year ago and then
Six months later it was six millimeters. So it doubled in size it grew three millimeters in six months
And then three months later
I let's say I started a protocol at that six month mark and then six months later
It's now you know it went from three to six now. It's let's say eight millimeters
Okay, well, it definitely slowed down. It's growth
So I would you know you're you're you're winning the battle somewhat here. Yeah, it's not completely gone
It's not shrinking. You just continue to reassess to know that you're going in the right direction as far as momentum goes
It's very rare that a person would go on any protocol and have there be major changes
Unless you want an extremely toxic protocol. You could have changes with chemo in a size of a tumor
more readily but
But again, not always so you want to reassess see if your treatment protocol
needs to be tweaked or things need to be changed
But I would say two months of a protocol and there's slight growth in a tumor. I would make major changes
Next question now that my numbers have gone back into normal range like psa
calcium, bioclin phosphatase. Do you still recommend they take the cancer dose for ivervectin?
Which is this person's case 48 milligrams a day
If so for how long and also do I need fan bed is all now I am
able to get it in capsule form
Is the cancer dose based upon weight alone or something else too by weight fluctuates a bit
Okay, so a couple different questions in here. Let's say okay, so this person's all signs
um and symptoms I believe for this person
Have shown great improvement his psa is a normal range calcium is back to normal alkaline phosphates back down
Should I keep taking the ivervectin?
Should I take continue take fan bed is all um
That is a you know if the person was talking about their supplements
I would say stay on it because there's no
negative effects of a supplement protocol
um
So why not stay on it, but there are negatives to taking drugs, okay?
ivervectin even though it has less side effects than fan bed is all still drunk
um and your body could get used to it so if your if your cancer has gone into remission
Should you stay on a ivervectin and or fan bed is all protocol personally?
I think no, I would cycle off. I would go off of them
um and I would again retest everything in a month or two months or three months and if everything stayed or
I'd stay off of them
um
So
The reason is is that ivervectin can have negative effects on your liver so can
fan bed is all we just got done discussing that huh can we have even more severe negative effects
So if i was in remission, I would not be taking drugs of any kind that's just me
um now there are other people like oh i want to stay there so i'm going to keep taking ivervectin
I would have you know go just pulse my fan bed is all
everybody has to make their own decisions just personally i wouldn't
So
This person had to say the question my answer would be I would go off of it
I would not take fan bed is all now i would just leave it
It's kind of like your saving
More dangerous treatment
In case i need it
um besides the fact that a cancer can get used to something
Could you use to chemo and chemo then it fails in its effectiveness
Can get used to fan bed is all in ivervectin so i would if i don't need it i wouldn't use it
um and then the second part of this question is
um the dosage is dosage based on weight the dosage is based on weight only for ivervectin
So ivervectin has a weight dependent dose
The fan bed is all doesn't so fan bed is all dose has a has a ramped dose
um that um you start at 222 milligrams
um of active drug dose per person three days on four days off
And then you you can ramp that up in multiple different ways
um by taking it every day or taking you know taking five days on two days off
or things like that or double that dose to four and 44 milligrams
This is all sorts of different ways to ramp
For the fan bed is all over again you would keep a close eye on your liver markers
Regardless of you and if you're on the starting dose
ivervectin's cancer dose is one half milligram per kilogram body weight
to start dose
But in full answer this question i would pause both of them
Next question how do you suggest nebulizing colloidal silver and the frequency um you can
Nebulize just about anything that can be dissolved in a liquid
One of the best things to nebulize for the lungs
Well, there's the hydrogen peroxide um and you do that based upon
The recipe that's on the members home site home page
So the recipe for nebulizing hydrogen peroxide is a downloadable PDF of the members home page
So that's good for a person's lungs that would be good for an infection of the lungs
That would be good for lung cancer
um
That's what it'd be good for for the lungs
colloidal silver
Can you nebulize colloidal silver? Yes, you can you would put that directly you don't water the colloidal silver
Now you put that directly in the nebulizer
How often could you do it? Well, you could do it daily um
Uh, you could alternate to the colloidal silver and the hydrogen peroxide
Um, there's different things that you could mix you could kind of mix up with that
But so there is no tried-in through you could only do it so many times and things like that
Um colloidal silver you can get too much colloidal silver um
But uh, you know, you don't have to be doing it
10 times a day probably to get too much colloidal silver
Okay questions from the chat here
So if you haven't chatted and you just go to the chat and start typing in a question if you want to chat in a question
If you don't know how to do that you can always unmute yourself and
verbally ask a question too
Do you have any thoughts on the pushback of the supplement AHCC for immune function
And if I have the MTHFR mutation step
Then I shouldn't be taking methylated V supplements
Well, you don't take methylated V supplements based upon your genetics
You take methylated V supplements based upon a blood test
measuring homocysteine
That's just my opinion you go to 99 out of 100 other naturopaths carpractors that do genetic testing
If they do
MTHFR defect testing and they see a defect they're going to put people on methylated supplements
That's where I differ in opinion. I'm sorry. I just think they're wrong
so
And even if a person doesn't have cancer, I still think that's wrong
For multiple reasons
Now I do list some of those in some of the videos
And I do have a blog post on should cancer patients take methylated supplements that explains that
And I've kind of gone over it a little bit already today
But methylated supplements for somebody as cancer
Can be harmful because they can turn off the gene expression of tumor suppressor genes
If you do that, your cancer could grow. You don't want to do that
So no, I don't think you should take B methylated B vitamins
Based upon genetic steps at all
You take that based upon
But only if you have elevated homocysteine levels
Well, I've taken my measure my homocysteine. It's normal. Well, then don't take that. Don't take methylated B supplements
Okay, next question
I am using immune stimulation programs to help the immune system. Is there any other program to increase immunity?
Um, no, I don't think so. So you increase your your
What is immunity first of all? So let's define our terms
So I want to increase my immunity. What does I mean? You want to increase your white blood cell count
You want to increase your lymphocyte account
You want to increase your nutritional account
So increase seen
Increasing account
lymphocytes. Can I do that by writing the right program?
No, I don't think so
What increases your immune system while your immune system will increase
Um will make more immune cells in the event that there's a pathogen attack
So I get an infection
I'm gonna have more white blood cells. That's what you measure
The complete blood count on a blood test
It has a normal range. So let's say the normal range of white blood cells
For if you look at a blood test it'll say four to 11 or something like that
But really the normal range of white blood cell count is like four to six point five maybe
And well, I want my white blood cell count higher because then that will help me
Kill off more pathogens
No, there's a normal range. You know, we always think that
You know, we're Americans so if this much is good for me then twice as much if you're really good for me
That's just how it works
Um
There's a if my white blood cell count is low
There's a reason it's not because I need to stimulate it
There's a reason why my white blood cell count is low
So let's say I do a complete blood count
And my white blood cell count is
2.5 percent
That's really low
Oh my gosh, I need to build it up
I'm gonna take some immune supplements I'm gonna do this and that well
Yes, that would be good, but there's a reason why it's low
We have to find the reason we got to ask why okay, so
Why is it low? Well, it could be low because I you know, I'm fighting a disease
So it could be low because I'm fighting cancer and my immune system is fatigue
So what do I do? Will you then that would be I'm gonna take immune supplements to help
Fight this disease. I'm gonna try to get rest. I'm gonna try to eat correctly
Um, how do my body make these immune cells? They make it through
Protein it might protein deficient in my diet. I need to be eating more protein
Um, there's all sorts of reasons why
But so what you look as a practitioner at a complete blood count
It helps you with differential diagnosis of what the problem is
If the person
Doesn't have a diagnosis of cancer or their cancer is in relative state of remission
But they have a suppressed white blood cell cope beating below
3.5 let's say
chronically then you have to think of does this person have a chronic viral infection a chronic infection
Be like there with this chronic Lyme disease or something or chronic Epstein bar virus
That could give that could express itself
At a complete blood count as a suppressed white blood cell count
So just taking a whole bunch of immune stimulants is not necessarily the way you would treat that
You would eat to do some further investigation to find out why
So if I have an autoimmune patient a chronically ill patient come to me. They don't have cancer
They just don't feel good and we do a cbc
With differential and they have a suppressed white blood cell count
It's a pretty good chance especially if you look at past blood tests
And it's been suppressed for the last three years that this person is dealing with a chronic infection
Then it's time to do some other antibody tests some pathogen antibody tests
Does this person have a chronic Epstein bar they have an IGM
Elevated antibody an Epstein bar virus that means they have a current
Epstein bar virus that they probably had for years this current
Infection of Epstein bar then you need to treat the Epstein bar
So how would you get to it? It's not a matter of manipulating the white blood cell count
You want to get the person better so that the white blood cell count is under the expression of their illness
Treat the illness so the white blood cell count will balance itself out
So now you start doing the right machine say the person has a right machine
You're running Epstein bar frequencies of that person
And then you're killing the Epstein bar and you look at a cbc again
And you see that white blood cell count go up and the person symptoms start to go down
And they start feeling better. Oh my gosh
You were just different. I'm a doctor. Oh, he's just asked the right questions
So you're not going to get the right answers if you don't ask the right questions
So um don't look at blood tests as
I need to get these back into range
What supplement can I take to get this back in range? That's a
That's a that's a
Mediciable way to look at something
That's not the way we want to look at things. We want to look at them holistically
If I have something out of range, I want to go why is it out of range? It's just a sigh
It's just like a beacon that's flashing telling me there's something wrong
I if I have a beacon flashing telling me there's something wrong. I could deal with it one of two ways
I could figure out why is that beacon it's flashing and fix that so the beacon stops flashing or I could just take up my pistol and you know
Um, 22 into the beacon. So it stops flashing now. I've solved it
That's kind of the medicinal way to look at things
My cholesterol is high. So I'm going to take lipitor. Oh my cholesterol is normal now
Oh, you did is figure out a drug that would lower cholesterol. You didn't solve why the cholesterol was high
So we don't want to use
Natural means to do the same thing
We don't want to say oh my white blood cell count is low
Is there some magic supplement that's going to raise my white blood cell count
If there was that wouldn't be the right approach
Is there a right problem that will increase my right white blood cell count?
I'm not trying to be facetious to the person asking the question. I think we all have these questions
We all just want to solve our problems, but we can't solve our problems by
by just
By not digging into finding out what the problem why the problems there in the first place
So if I want to if if this person said I didn't even look at my I don't know what you're talking about with a complete blood
I just want to increase my immunity so I don't get sick
Um, well, how we increase our immunity so we don't get sick is
We want to be exposed to pathogens
You know the worst things you could do is not be exposed to
Everyday pathogens because that's what actually builds your immune system
So the definition of a healthy immune system is what I have circulated antibodies against a lot of different pathogens
Because I was exposed to strep because my little kid came home with strep and I was exposed to strep and I fired it
TH water response and a TH2 response which is a B cell response which made antibodies against strep
How I have circulated anybody's against streps and how we go to work and somebody else had strep
I don't get sick at all, but three of my coworkers are sick
But I didn't get sick because I've been exposed to these things
We don't shelter ourselves and wash our hands with and the bacterial soap and
And wear masks and do all these foolish things that we're going to not be exposed to pathogens
You actually want to be exposed to pathogens so that your immune system
Exantibodies against said pathogens and now you have circulated antibodies against multiple different pathogens
That will keep you from getting sick. That's what a healthy immune system is
And when I have issues with you know blood tests when I have objective signs or subjective symptoms that
Is is making me feel ill you want to always dig to reasons why
And then you fix that reason why and and then the objective side will improve and the subjective symptoms will improve so
Say it too much for this question, but hope that helps. All right, next question
Come on, government
I'm making it elderberry syrup like dried elderberries raw honey
raw apple cider and water for my family for winter months
Is this something I could use on occasion in for upcoming illness thoughts on elderberry in general. So elderberry
It's great all these things that you're talking about it is great
There's a lot of people making a fire cider things like that all good things
Those are good things to build your immune system quote-unquote to keep a healthy immune system
Just like we talked about in the last question to help your body be able to fight disease
So a lot of these things like elderberries and a lot of like echinacea and
and things
Gar like can kill directly so they can kill pathogens in your gut directly
Next question I had a myopsy and a dermatologist
a lesion above my brow
Recommendation is to do freezing the tissue around the area since the pathogen came back pre-cancer
Does it sound like a good idea?
I have not done well with the other two biopsies on a leg
Not cancerous and freezing of a liver abroad spot slowly healing
Um does it sound like a good idea? Well, you're talking to somebody who doesn't like doctors, okay?
So I don't know
When I do that
Is that mean you should not do that? No, it doesn't mean that you shouldn't do it
Um the negatives about removing skin lesions
So that there's negatives
So if I have a skin lesion that looks like it could be a melanoma
Should I get a biopsy to get a diagnosis and have them do a surgical procedure to remove it?
That's typically called mose surgery
um
If I have to give you the right medical answer the right medical answer is yes, you should do that
If I have to give you the alternative my opinion
This is just solely my opinion. I would never
surgically remove what I think could be a melanoma
Is there any harm in removing what is obviously a basal cell?
No, it's never rare very rarely going to become malignant
You could remove a basal cell cancer
How about another cancer that's and you could easily google what a basal cell cancer looks like they look very different
than a squabous cell cancer or a melanoma
So it's very easy
Or even an untrained eye to know what a basal cell cancer is
Should I remove a
lesion on my skin that looks like it could be a
A cancerous lesion definitely isn't basal cell, but it could be melanoma or it could be squabous cell
Personally, I don't think so the danger of cutting into it and doing that could spread it all over now
I know there's a million examples of people that had a melanoma removed and they never had any problems with it
But there's also a million people that have had a melanoma removed and it's spread it all over and they have a melanoma that is gone
metastasized so that's an extremely difficult cancer to treat
What else are you going to do? There's other things a person could do you could use different
uh
Surface applied treatments that are natural from essential oils to a curcumin cream to black salve to all these different things
But you have to be mentally prepared and there's some work involved with it
So if you don't want to be responsible
I just want the doctors take this off and get this out of here and get this rid of me
And I want to get it out of there and by all means go and do that
If you if that's just your temperament everybody's different human being
And as a believer you need to be proud about these decisions maybe it's the right thing to do
It's the best thing to do it's the absolute right thing to do for you
So I'm not against medical care. I'm just personally you just ask me my opinion what I do
I don't know that I would do that but that doesn't mean that it's wrong for you
Especially given your history I'm not healing from these things and
I don't that's just my opinion but uh you know I don't want
to
I get what you maybe are called to do
Next question is methylene blue considered something you don't want to take as a cancer patient?
No
If that's not a methylated supplement so you can take that that's just the name of the dye
That is used just uh if you're going to take methylene blue make sure
You're only taking you to a couple drops a day
So again don't fall into the
The American standard of will have two drops are good for you then 10 drops must be really good for you do not do that
Stay in a very very low dosage of it
Next question how often should liver levels be checked
even
When doing friendband is on at least on a monthly basis
But I have some people that detoxify friendband is all just fine
They've done it monthly and it's never raised their
ALT and AST it's never raised their liver markers and then they don't have to necessarily do it monthly
Again, I think it splits about 50 50
50% of the people just don't detoxify it well at all and their liver markers start to go up
Those are the people that need to be more diligent in getting their numbers checked
Oh question
Thanks for being on everybody
Sorry for the long answers and
We'll see you guys next week have a good weekend. We got a blizzard here. We're still trying to dig our way out of it
Hey, but in the Midwest is dealing with the same thing
All right, bye-bye